[Music]
we're inside
this lg tunnel there are 246 55-inch
televisions inside of this tunnel
and it has all of the dolby atmos
surround sound so it really feels
like you are in these places like we are
right now soaring in the sky
thank you this is the lg chloe now these
are concept robots that can do multiple
things there's one to bring you room
service there's one that can potentially
check you into your hotel and there's
one that may one day
replace shopping carts one of the key
things that i've noticed here at zs this
year
is integrating google and alexa into
other things this is all using google
assistant but you don't even have to say
hey google and it's integrated into the
remote
change light brightness to 100
change lights to blue
search youtube videos for ijustine
oh oh what do you know so basically you
can use the remote control for your
television to control your lights to
control your entire home so basically
change the color of the lights
turn on air purifier i can turn on the
air conditioner this is why
i don't ever have to leave my house
this is actually a pretty cool demo
we'll have tvs in different locations
it's really hard to be able to see from
different angles
with these they have an accurate color
angle so no matter what angle you're at
you can see all the colors at much more
of a true depth
the bottom is conventional and this is
the top where you can see
the accurate color angles
[Music]
we're heading in to get a demo of this
4k hdr projector you can scale this up
to 150 inches
wow this is actually shocking at the
picture quality
because this looks like a television but
it is a projector the colors are so
vibrant the lifespan of this projector
is over 20 000 hours
basically you can watch this projector
for eight hours a day for seven years
straight i can spend my time quite
wisely watching plenty of netflix shows
on this thing
you guys know i'm always struggling with
monitor solutions and i'm trying out so
many
and i've seen a bunch of people try the
ultra wide monitors and i think this may
be the solution that i need
for editing
basically just taking a little rest here
at ces a cescs
though siesta siesta
i'm getting such inspiration goals all
of these
mock living rooms why can i not be an
adult and why does my house
never look nice
[Music]
we made it to the sony booth let's go
check it out
i'm shook i've run into so many people
this this trip
okay you can do you wanna
see what i got so this here is like a
little timeline of the past several
years of sewing cameras it's showing
where they started from
and where they are now you know it's
kind of like that drake song
started from the bottom now we're here
jenna did you see this
they have an a9 with a new sony rx0 on
top of it is there tiny new little
action camera that you guys see me talk
about they also have a bunch of
different adapters and cages for this
thing too so you basically
take this rx0 and do so many different
things with it they have a filter
adapter
camera cage they have housing the camera
control box
there's the camera itself here is a tear
down of everything that's inside of it
and this is a really
i hate to say it i don't like saying
aesthetic but this is a very
aesthetically pleasing tear down photo
[Music]
this is ibo and it's kind of crazy
because he has a lot of artificial
intelligence built into him he can
recognize up to five family members
imagine there being like seven people in
your family and he's like sorry
wait remember when you thought dogs only
had three toes this one does
he does actually this is depending on
how the person treats the dog it'll
respond differently
so if jenna is nicer to the dog than i
am it's gonna like you more
so this is ibo it isn't concept it's
actually a real product they said that
you can only get it right now in japan
and it's sold out so maybe we just go to
japan and maybe we can find one
look he's even got little toys too so
this is his little puppy pad and if it's
blocked and he can't find it he has a
little tiny camera on his little butt
right here
that'll use the ceiling and he'll be
able to navigate his way back home
because he can tell and remember
that there are two lights on the ceiling
[Music]
did you say you wanted to go see
shirtless man maybe get b-roll
it's okay i'll go shoot him 240.
the clarification of what's going on the
rx0 that i was just talking about
they're doing bullet time they have 16
of them up here so it's capturing him
real time
and doing the matrix effect it looks
really crazy
i think
[Music]
so this is one of the actual intel
drones if you guys have seen any of the
synchronized droning that they've been
doing they have a really cool demo that
they're doing here at vegas
over 250 drones are synchronized
together to create this incredible
experience
every night from eight to 10 they're
flying these at the bellagio and it is
amazing but i'm holding one right in my
hand
surprisingly this thing is very light
here's your drone back
thank you
hey this is saf from supersaf tv as you
can see in the people you said that
you've been struggling because you
haven't filmed
anything either i i literally i think
i've filmed like three clips
in this whole time what's great is i
think ces is more about the people like
seeing everybody when was the last time
we met new york yeah but is there
anything really cool that you've seen
the huge tv from samsung 146 inches i
kind of want that on my wall it's pretty
crazy too because it's modular so you
can
have as many as you want exactly so you
could just like have an
entire wall of just this place and it
was so busy there as well like i was
trying to get some shots of it but there
was like
100 people in front of it this furniture
is smart furniture
it's enabled with bixby so instead of
yelling over to the other room say hey
refrigerator what's in my fridge
you can basically talk to the coffee
table you can
talk to your chair did you see the
refrigerator that can basically
preheat your oven and you say okay
fridge preheat the oven like it's it's
actually crazy how big
is it integrating into everything i have
the family hub 2.0
do you no we don't are you serious i
don't have the new one though but still
but i have it is pretty insane it's it's
one of those things that
you don't need until you have it but
it's awesome i can see what's in my
fridge right now
it's insane do you want to show us in
your fridge um
probably not okay it's a bit of a mess
well if i would look in my fridge
there's probably spoiled eggs and just a
bunch of like coffee so we're at the dti
booth and they announced the osmo mobile
and the ronin s did you get a chance to
check it out yet i have checked out both
there's going to be two versions of it
there's so this one the one that they've
got is for the dslrs but they're gonna
have a smaller version
mirrorless apparently and i think that
might be a bit more manageable awesome
well thanks for being in my video
thank you for having me i'm gonna put my
microphone back now
okay bye
[Music]
something that i've been super excited
to see is the new razer phone you guys
know that i absolutely
love phones of course i'm a huge iphone
fan they just announced a razer laptop
that basically integrates with the razer
phone where a normal trackpad would be
that's where the phone goes so you guys
know i'm a huge huge light bulbs fan but
guess what razer now has an integration
with you so you can basically customize
all of your razer led products
with hue lights with chroma studio
i can now configure all my lights at the
same time
and i can also position them based on
how they're physically located
in my room that's so cool i've actually
never seen the speakers before those are
awesome yeah those are actually our
brand new speakers we just lost on
tuesday
okay that's probably why i haven't seen
it i was like is this something how do i
not know
if you have a favorite song or a gym or
even you want to type up your channel
oh my yeah goodness
this isn't the censored version listen
give it to yourself
i usually listen to the censored version
so i'm a little shocked because it's
been a while since i've heard the full
remix
all right guys that does it for ces
2018. we're about to now embark on a
journey back home to la and we're
driving so
wish us luck unfortunately i don't have
a self-driving car but that's all right
maybe in the future oh gosh how long do
you think it's going to take jen
a long time all right
yes of course
[Music]